[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique la
police et la gendarmerie française
accusée de racisme après la mort de
georges floyd aux états unis cet afro
américain est devenu un symbole
planétaire
quelques milliers de manifestants ont
protesté hier en france contre les
inégalités et les violences policières
mardi c'est la famille d'adama traoré
qui a réclamé justice le jeune homme de
24 ans qui est mort lors de son
interpellation après un délit de fuite
dans le val d'oise
il y a quatre ans et notre raciale la
contagion c'est notre débat ce soir avec
lydia guirous ce essayiste et ancien
porte parole et républicains bonsoir
lydia guirous nous sommes également avec
florian philippot conseil régional du
grand test et président des patriotes
bonsoir florian philippot merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'être sur rt france
mercredi le ministre de l'intérieur a
réagi aux manifestations de soutien
adama traoré
le ministre de l'intérieur était
auditionné devant le sénat et coûter
il faut faire en sorte que chaque faute
et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot y compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction et je suis
sur ce sujet intransigeant parce que et
l'exigence que nous avons vis-à-vis des
policiers qui faudrait c'est garantir
justement la sérénité du travail de
l'ensemble de la police et de la
gendarmerie c'est garantir la défense de
cette police républicaine qui au
quotidien combat combat le racisme
combat l'antisémitisme et s'engage au
quotidien pour défendre l'honneur de la
république
enfin florian philippot que pensez vous
de ces manifestations dans le sillage de
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
ont-elles doivent-elles avoir lieu en
france
on rappelle que les gendarmes et les
policiers sont qualifiés de racistes est
ce que c'est le cas selon vous mais moi
ce qui me fascine dans cette affaire
c'est que ça sort absolument nulle part
en france il n'y a aucune actualité
aucune rien du tout ils ont trouvé un
groupe facebook ou quelques policiers
avaient des propos racistes
inadmissibles d'accord une
actualité ya le rapport d'autopsié
d'aude adama traoré qui a été
concomitant avec ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis
adama traoré c'était en 2016 on nous le
ressort régulièrement c'est une affaire
qui n'est pas comparable à georges floyd
on est sur une famille traoré que celui
de délinquant notoire à l'extraire mais
il ya eu déjà des expertises médicales
qui allait elle dans le sens les
gendarmes ne faut pas oublier non plus
on n'a pas de témoins on n'a pas de film
et donc moi j'ai pas envie de jeter
comme ça le prof si on descend des
gendarmes alors qu'on n'a aucun élément
concret pour le faire on est vraiment
dans le contrat victoire et la justice
nous dira ce qui s'est passé ici je n'y
a pas de y'a pas d'actualité en france
on voit bien que ça un mouvement
communautariste ces deux chocs fait sur
ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
d'importer un contexte américain qui n'a
rien à voir la question noire aux
etats-unis elle s'inscrit dans une
histoire celle de l'esclavagé et de la
ségrégation celle de la lutte pour les
droits civiques dans les années 50 et
les années 60 où il y avait encore des
discriminations légales dans l'espace
public dans ce pays
alors quand je pense au même moment nous
avions un président du sénat qui était
noir deuxième personnage de l'état
on n'a pas la même histoire les
violences policières oui ça existe en
france on en a beaucoup parlé moment des
gilet jaune mais c'était pas une couleur
de peau pour le coup il ya des gens qui
ont perdu la vie qui ont perdu un oeil
qui ont perdu une main leur seule valeur
c'est qu'ils avaient plutôt du jaune sûr
que plutôt que d'être noir ou blanc de
peau et donc c'était plutôt un problème
politique et sociale donc je trouve que
c'est cette affaire n'a pas de sens
il faut les regarder d'ailleurs qui
soutient et qui finance ces mouvements
et je pense que le seul qui que ça
arrange dans cette affaire c'est le
monsieur véran parce que pendant ce
temps là on parle plus du drame du
coronavirus cette très mauvaise gestion
et ça arrange aura été le pouvoir parce
que on est dans une situation de crise
économique absolument inédite effroyable
et pendant ce temps là on parle d'un
sujet qui en fait a été mis
artificiellement en haut de l'agenda
commencez-vous lydia guirous c'est ce
que adama traoré pourrait être le genre
jeu floyd français vous vous sentez
concerné vous qui êtes aussi issus de
l'immigration à lydia guirous ce qu'en
pensez vous alors moi je
je ne crois pas que adama traoré soit le
genre gersois et georges tron rappelons
quand même ces images de cet homme qui
dit je n'arrive plus à respirer et ce
policier qui appuie avec nos semblables
son genou assure sur son cou et il est
en train de changer leurs demeures
devant devant différents témoins c'est
absolument insoutenable a évidemment on
peut que s'émouvoir condamné et espérer
une condamnation de ce policier mais les
états unis quelques arbres pardon si
quelqu'un il a été arrêté
bien sûr et comme l'a dit florian
philippot les états unis l'histoire des
états unis histoire l'histoire noire des
noirs américains aux états unis n'est
absolument pas la même que celle de des
minorités qui se disent en france
victimes du racisme systémique de la
police voire d'une violence de l'êta je
crois que la famille d'adama traoré est
en train notamment sa soeur est en train
d'essayer d'instrumentaliser le drame de
georges floyd aux états unis essayé
d'importer la question raciale en france
pour installer un communautarisme et une
vision à racialise de la société
française nous sommes universaliste et
je crois que ce serait une erreur
majeure qui d'ailleurs un portrait
préjudice d'abord aux personnes issues
des minorités
puisque c'est comme ça pour mon on parle
des personnes qui ont des origines
étrangères en c1 c'est malheureusement
je ne partage pas mais mais c'est ainsi
et ça portera préjudice donc aux
personnes issues des minorités des
personnes qui sont d'origine maghrébine
ou africaine ou antillaise
il faut garder à l'esprit la vision
française l'universalisme nous sommes
des citoyens avant tout qu'importe notre
couleur de peau et surtout se tenir loin
du modèle américain que certains ont
essayé de nous vendre depuis des années
en disant que c'était extraordinaire la
discrimination positive le la diversité
toutes ces choses les etats unis c'est
aussi les émeutes raciales c'est aussi
cette haine entre les différentes
communautés qui ne se rencontrent pas la
france elle a un modèle que j'aimerais
voir exporter à l'étranger et surtout
je crois que nous avons affaire à des
semeurs de troubles notamment à la third
adama traoré et toutes les organisations
à d'extrême gauche qui sont qui sont
autour d'eux et qu'ils sont en train
d'essayer d'accélérer la scission et la
partition de la france je voudrais qu'on
écoute aujourd'hui la réaction de
christian jacob damien abad également a
réagi hier des républicains écoutez pour
lui les violences policières ça n'existe
pas écoutez des violences policières en
france et c'est un mensonge
ça n'existe pas on a vu des violences de
manifestants mais jamais de violences
policières en france n'a pas une police
racistes en france n'existe pas par
contre la police comme d'ailleurs tous
les autres corps de métiers comme
échappé à certains individus qui
effectivement présente une expression
raciste il n'y aurait donc pas de
racisme institutionnalisé
florian philippot vous êtes d'accord
avec ce que dit damien abad où christian
jacob
alors on parle d'un côté évidemment des
violences policières et du racisme de
l'autre on a tendance un peu à les
mettre dans le même panier si je puis
dire oui il ya deux choses différentes
lui dire il n'y a pas de violences
policières c'est idiot il y à il ya eu
des violences le policière on sait très
bien aussi bien d'ailleurs contre des
gilet jaune jean paraît extrêmement
d'ailleurs brutale inédite dans notre
histoire ça c'est le sage bon là qu'on
aurait dû beaucoup en parler et que
d'ailleurs on n'en parlait pas beaucoup
enfin moi j'essayais d'en parler avec
quelques autres il n'en parlait pas
beaucoup et je mets je me mets le move
est de 2 je me vais devoir que le qu'il
n'y avait pas de dents quête sérieuse et
rapide de la part de l'igpn est et de la
justice qu'il y ait de te dire qu'il
n'ya pas de racisme systémique dans la
police oui bien sûr dieu merci il n'y a
pas de racisme si stellistes insultant
de dire cela pour nos forces de l'ordre
de toute façon la notion de racisme
systémique qui est une notion que les
indigéniste essaie d'imposer en france
qui est une vision américaine
c'est une vision raciste parce que ça
consiste à dire que par définition dès
qu'il met le blanc un privilège c'est le
fameux privilège blanc dont il nous
parle mais c'est une vision est
épouvantablement raciste ça consiste
sans considère que le blanc n'a pas de
l'idée
tu es individuel n'est pas une personne
douée d'un d'une réflexion propre et
d'un sens critique et d'une réflexion
politique il serait par nature par une
sorte de péché originel en naissant déjà
raciste système de manière systémique
je trouve que c'est là c'est le racisme
là c'est du vrai racisme il faut
regarder la question des violences
policières
en face il faut pas le nier il faut
regarder la question du racisme quand
elles existent dans tous les sens
d'ailleurs un racisme y compris
anti-blanc anti-noir entière à tous que
vous les anti asiatique il ya du racisme
dans tous les sens mais il faut pas les
coûts essayer de faire croire aux
français que notre police serait de
manière systémique assiste là je pense
que c'est un mensonge c'est une
manipulation et moi je m'adresse à nos
compatriotes d'origine étrangère jordy
ne tombez pas dans le panneau
effectivement la soeur de l'adama traoré
et les organisations indigènes is
communautariste autour vous manipulent
ils essaient de vous récupérer dans des
mouvements qui ne sont pas allées
l'autre ce sont des mouvements de haine
et de division
on va avoir besoin dans les mois qui
viennent de se serrer les coudes tous
face à nos battre face à ceux qui font
du mal à la france face à ceux qui font
du mal aux travailleurs français qu'on
soit le noir ou blanc on va devoir se
serrer les coudes
ne tombez pas dans le panneau de ces
gens là ces gens là reçoit beaucoup de
soutien ils sont soutenus par des très
grandes entreprises qui sont soutenus
par les gars femmes ils sont soutenus
par les stars les ariane sas est suspect
rien que ça ça doit vous alerter
ça n'est pas un combat populaire qu'il
mène un combat pour eux pour leur
notoriété et pour leur petite petite
fortune personnelle alors avancé ces
manifestations il y avait la semaine
dernière cette déclaration de camélia
jordana chanteuse et comédienne qui
avait choqué l'opinion
on l'écouté et on écoutera votre
réaction après lydia guirous mais les
manifestants hommes et des femmes qui
vont travailler tous les matins en
banlieue oui qui se font massacrer pour
nulle autre raison que leurs couleurs de
leur club pour le ch à 7 un cdd gens qui
se font massacrés pour leur couleur de
peau
ce genre de discours lydia guirous ce
qu'en pensez-vous à est-ce que c'est
contreproductif et contreproductif c'est
mon songe et c'est ridicule camilla
jordana devra se contenter de
de chanter je pense qu'elle a un
problème en ce moment peut-être pour
vendre ses disques et se repositionne
sur un marketing un peu ethnique
je regrette qu'elle qu'elle tombe dans
le piège des dessins d'hygiéniste c'est
vraiment extrêmement dangereux non en
france je ne fais pas massacrer pour
pour sa couleur de peau et je crois
qu'elle est d'origine maghrébine qu'elle
a plutôt bien vécu en france il faudrait
quand même être parfois reconnaissant et
arrêter d'être toujours dans le french
bashing dans la république bashing voilà
quelques les artistes et je trouve que
depuis la crise du corner youth mai même
lors de nombreuses autres crises
prennent la parole sur des sujets
politiques extrêmement sensible et ils
ne rendent service à personne parce que
souvent ils sont à côté de la plaque et
j'ai l'impression que camélia jordana
est un peu en perdition en se prenant
pour une espèce de black panthères sous
je ne je ne sais quoi en chantant le
poing levé et en appelant à prendre les
armes
c'est mettre de l'huile sur le feu c'est
c'est ridicule ce n'est pas sa place et
il faudrait que ces artistes continuent
d'être des artistes mais surtout qu'ils
ne viennent pas sur des sujets aussi
sensibles aussi brûlant au moment où la
france a besoin d'apaisement et de
réconciliation
une enquête très intéressante publiée
aujourd'hui dans le jdd florian
philippot les l'igpn annonça un chiffre
officiel qui contredit finalement les
accusations portées contre la police au
sujet du racisme les enquêtes pour
injures racistes auraient diminué
l'année dernière elles sont en recul 30
recensés en 2019 contre 46 en 2018 alors
il ya évidemment ce groupe facebook
aussi qui fait beaucoup parler
c'est la tendance c'est quoi cette
généralisée finalement qui qui peut être
qui peut être nocif en tout cas dans le
débat la tendance est à emporter un
sujet qui n'eut qui en france n'existe
qu'à pas d'actualité qui n'a pas
d'actualité encore une fois c'est de
singer les américains lilia jordan a
effectivement à pousser la chansonnette
en anglo américain le poing levé c'est
est d'un ridicule d'un grotesque je
pense que le pire c'est qu'elle y croit
elle pense vraiment faire la révolution
avec sur le dans le dos nike
facebook et twitter coller comme
sponsors parce que c'est le cas ils sont
ces gens là sont sponsorisés par ces
grandes entreprises gagnent ça ça pour
le ridicule de la situation
les gilets jaunes eux n'ont jamais été
soutenu par nike facebook et twitter
rencontrait donc plutôt été sacrément
diaboliser ce qui prouve qu'ils
touchaient au juste voilà donc moi je
voulais j'ai envie de dire faites
attention à ces mouvements ils sont
souvent les vrais racistes sont souvent
là moi j'ai eu hier et avant-hier une
scène très chaud quand j'ai vu un
policier noir qui était interpellé par
une militante de ces deux manifestations
qu'il l'a traité de vendu philippot
cette vidéo est et on en parle
volontiers
on voit là vous parliez de cette vidéo
forian filet pour l'action c'est chic
est une c'est d'avoir ce titre une
cinglée c'est une fille haineuse et ça
se voit les singles est complètement
folle et c'était les racistes au cardié
degrés il faut qu'elle s'en rende compte
vocation à condamner il a porté plainte
et il a eu bien raison
moi je me mets à sa place était honteuse
qui lui ont fait qu'on te considérais
qu'il serait déterminé donc par sa
couleur de peau mais c'est une vision
tribales des choses qu une vision
raciste
j'ai entendu hier dalles des gens et
dieu sait que je n'aime pas pourtant je
la défends pour le coup parce qu'il faut
défendre le principe des gens des
manifestants du cran traité cib et
n'diaye de traître parce que lé ministre
de la république française mais noir
mais on se rend compte du niveau de
racisme de tout cela les vrais racistes
ils sont là ils sont évidemment là ces
gens là doivent payer cher il faut que
on s'applique à eux les peines prévues
contre le racisme
évidemment en plus d'être complètement
plein de rage plein de haine plein de
colère de lier les plein de bêtises
surtout voilà moi j'ai beaucoup de
mépris pour ces gens là parce qu'ils
sont fondamentalement bête et qu'il ne
mérite que notre mépris donc français
deux françaises français d'origine
étrangère de tomber surtout pas dans le
panneau n'allait pas avec ces gens là
ils ne vous le veulent absolument pas du
bien ils ne défendent pas votre cause
ils vous font énormément de tort lydia
guirous ce le disais tout à l'heure
oui je pense que vous seriez les
premières victimes de ces mouvements là
parce qu'ils veulent vous m
à part on a compris le message à lorient
il faut une assimilation
on a compris le message on va regarder
quand même ce cas ce qu'on a dit jean
luc mélenchon il dit aussi que les
insultes sont des deux côtés regarde la
masse de la jeunesse de ce pays et
antiracistes et a subi des humiliations
sans arrêt les gens n'en peuvent plus
quatre cinq six contrôles par jour les
gens n'en peuvent plus se faire traiter
de [ __ ] ou de [ __ ] les gens n'en
peuvent plus alors c'est aussi un fait
on va pas généraliser évidemment mais il
ya des insultes des deux côtés les
contrôles au faciès qui sont souvent
dénoncé lydia guirous c'est un problème
auquel il va falloir remédier mais vous
avez la police est l'une des professions
les plus contrôlés notamment par l'igpn
il ya eu ce groupe facebook de policiers
de gendarmes où il ya eu des propos
absolument abjecte raciste misogyne
antisémites homophobes et je souhaite
que ceux qui ont tenu ces propos là soit
condamné parce que ce n'est pas
tolérable ensemble de la police
nationale c'est c'est un des piliers de
notre république et la confiance elle
reviendra aussi comme ça mais ce n'est
pas l'institution qui est raciste ya des
brebis galeuses
la police elle est à l'image de la
société ce sont des hommes et des femmes
avec leurs qualités ne sait avec le
retard certains sont en séance et sont
ces erreurs là de deux jugements
il faut aussi rappeler leurs conditions
leurs conditions de travail
c'est une c'est une profession où ils
sont menacés agressés à huy sont dans
des guets-apens où ils ont des
conditions de travail qui sont
extrêmement difficile où leur salaire ne
sont pas valorisés alors ça n'excuse pas
ce qui à thiennes des propos racistes
mais je pense que si on ne les considère
pas davantage là ces personnes seront
amenés à dévier petit à petit je voulais
rebondir sur ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur le racisme les indigéniste
les racialiste qui veulent importer des
questions américaines en france
calquella le communautarisme américain
en france
son rôle est raciste moi depuis le début
de mon engagement politique
je subis des insultes quotidiennes avec
tables harcèlement quotidien on insulte
de colabor de traîtres et j'en passe on
a l'impression qu'on a substitué une
forme de déterminisme social un
déterminisme ethnico racial maintenant
avec ces personnes là si vous êtes de
quelle origine vous devez penser de
telle façon il n'ya plus de libre
arbitre
nous n'avons plus le droit à l'esprit
critique nous n'avons plus le droit de
choisir librement nos engagements et ses
essais de plus en plus présents jeux en
cinq ans je n'ai vu ce phénomène que
s'accentuer alors cib et ndèye en a été
victime
ce policier a été insultée devant du met
ces quotidiens pour toutes les personnes
qui refusent de tomber dans un piège
communautariste dans le piège de
l'islamisme aussi dans le piège d un
d'hygiéniste et ça devient extrêmement
difficile quand vous êtes d'origine
maghrébine ou africaine de pouvoir
choisir librement vos engagements de
pouvoir choisir la république sans avoir
à subir cette pression là et les
soutiens sont assez peu nombreux et
comme le dit un florent petit pot
surtout surtout ne tombons pas dans le
piège et qui est mortifère pour toute la
jeunesse de 2
voilà deux séquences pardon de france la
jeunesse de france et celle de cette
impasse des relations d'une vision voilà
racialiste des personnes voyons des
hommes et des femmes et pas seulement
des couleurs de peau ou des religions et
ça va être véritablement je pense en un
combat à mener dans les prochaines
années
qui va être très très difficiles à
gagner parce que des mouvements
minoritaires qui sont en train de
travailler sont extrêmement déterminé
organisé et financé un dernier mot
florian philippot le silence de
l'exécutif sur cette question on n'a pas
entendu ni le premier ministre ni
emmanuel macron s'exprimer contrairement
à donald trump aux états unis mais moi
je pense que c'est honnêtement tout
bénéfice pour eux pendant ce temps là on
ferait mieux de s'intéresser à la
situation de l'hôpital en plus me parler
des conflits d'intérêts en milieu
pharmaceutique avec le puits ce qui
s'est passé dans les débats sont hydroxy
franquine la fosse étude du land 7 c'est
gravissime cette affaire la prise en
main de la santé par des lobbys ont fait
mieux parler de la question de l'union
européenne cette défaillance gravissime
de la production industrielle qui est
parti dont on a payé le prix fort de ce
qui s'est passé dans les ehpad la crise
économique les millions de chômeurs en
plus là on a un mois et demi ça je veux
dire si voilà c'est du sérieux
c'est du sérieux les 11% de récession
cette année on n'a pas eu ça en france
depuis 300 ans
donc je pense que ça arrange emmanuel
baron edouard fit d'ailleurs la preuve
si vraiment il y avait un racisme
systémique en france cette manifestation
pourtant interdite de 20 mille personnes
à la peine de sa traoré devant le tgi
paris d'autres soir n'aurait pas fait
l'objet de seulement 18 interpellations
voilà dix-huit interpellations sur 20000
manifestants en situation de
manifestations illégales ce qu'il trouve
que quand même on est loin du racisme
systémique en france on est plutôt dans
la manifestation qui le dérange pas
beaucoup de pouvoir
merci beaucoup florian philippot merci
beaucoup à lydia guirous également
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est la
fin de ce débat politique du week end le
journal à suivre dans quelques minutes
[Musique]